Bobby Kennedy of the subjects of David
Talbots new book brothers he looks at
the political and personal relationship
between the president and his Attorney
General from the book passage bookstore
in San Francisco this is an hour
good evening and welcome to book passage
you are small but feisty independent
bookstore with what we think is the best
view in the city tonight's guest is
David Talbott who's come to tell us
about brothers the hidden history of the
Kennedy years David Talbott was born and
raised in Los Angeles he has been a
lifelong activist and provocateur going
way back to days at Harvard Preparatory
School in Southern California and also
UC Santa Cruz he comes by this activism
quite naturally since his father was
Lyle Talbot the movie and television
actor and left-wing labor activist who
co-founded the Screen Actors Guild
[Music]
after UC Santa Cruz
mr. talbert wrote in 1978 creative
differences profiles of Hollywood
dissidents and in 1989 burning desires
sex in America a report from the field
after that he was senior editor Mother
Jones magazine for five years and after
that he was an editor at the Examiners
image magazine from 1985 to 1994 when
the examiner was still in newspaper and
not the story publication that it is
today
in 1995 he founded salon.com and was
editor-in-chief and CEO at salon.com for
10 years he is now chairman of the board
please welcome David Talbott thank you
very much for that introduction it
sounded like my FBI file points well I
had some prepared remarks tonight but
I'm gonna put them aside and just read
to you Vincent Bugliosi the entire 16
hundred page book an answer at point by
plane if you'll just bear with me for
the next several weeks no but seriously
I would like to I would like to begin
with just a few remarks and then to
impose on you by reading a bit from the
book if I could and then answering any
questions you might have and then just
going out and enjoying this evening
before it's it's gone this beautiful
night all of you staring dreamily pastor
yeah well they say history is a
never-ending argument and if that's the
case my book brothers makes too
main arguments I believe one is that
Bobby Kennedy was the country's first
assassination conspiracy theorist and
number two and this is turning out to be
the most controversial aspect of my book
from the at least some of the early
reviews is that the Kennedys were heroes
and they were heroes for the simple
reason that they kept us out of war as I
say this has become controversial
because in the last 20 years or more
we've been going through a revisionist
interpretation of the Kennedy presidency
it didn't start with Seymour Hersh his
dark side of Camelot but of course that
belt best-selling book definitely was
part of this backlash against the
Kennedys that book portrayed President
Kennedy is a decadent prince reckless
someone who put the country at risk
we now have journalists as prominent as
Chris Hitchens who dismissively refer to
JFK is a vulgar hoodlum and even in
academia the picture of JFK as a Cold
War militant has taken firmly hold but I
hope my book is a part of a third wave
of scholarship that challenges this
revisionist look at JFK my book
concentrates on the tumultuous inner
life of the Kennedy presidency it was a
presidency that I think was a government
at war with itself
I call it Rome on the Potomac an air of
sinister menace hung over the Kennedy
presidency as JFK I believe tried to
lead the country out of the Cold War
before his time this provoked a sharp
backlash from very powerful forces in
the US we know remember President
Eisenhower's famous farewell address to
the nation which he warned us of the
encroaching power of the
military-industrial complex
Kennedy soon found out how powerful
these forces were at the Bay of Pigs
which was the first great crisis in
his administration the failed invasion
of Cuba that the CIA had orchestrated
and told him in to use language from
today's CIA world it was a slam-dunk it
turned out not to be of course it was a
disaster and Kennedy later feeling
sandbagged by the CIA and furious at the
intelligence they'd given him vowed to
shatter the CIA into a thousand pieces
and scatter it to the winds the national
security establishment was equally
enraged at Kennedy I think my if I if my
book does one thing I hope it it creates
a sense of what the Kennedys were up
against because most books don't evoke
this kind of poisonous atmosphere that
prevailed in Washington in those years
when you read the oral histories under
or do interviews with people who are
still alive from this world the
intelligence world the military world
you get a sense of the of the vitriol
the hatred that they had for the
Kennedys Curtis LeMay the notorious head
of the air force referred to them as
cockroaches who should have been crushed
JFK in return thought of LeMay was a
madman LeMay of course thought you could
actually fight and win a nuclear war and
he was determined to do this while the
United States had nuclear superiority in
the early 60s at one point he stunned a
dinner made at a Georgetown dinner party
turning to this woman who happened to be
the wife of a u.s. senator and saying
we're going to have a nuclear war with
the Soviet Union before the end of the
year and if you want you and your
children and grandchildren to survive
you should take them out west to
tumbleweed country and that was her only
chance of surviving John Kennedy was a
very different man he was determined he
knew what the nuclear stakes were and he
was determined to keep the country from
falling into that precipice in his
famous speech at American University in
June 1963 I think we see the visionary
Kennedy at his best the speech written
for him by Theodore Sorensen his
eloquent speech writer and we can't even
imagine a leader today you
in these words and at the height of the
Cold War imagine the the revolutionary
message of this speech in which he says
we must empathize with our enemy no
matter how repellent the value systems
of governments that we oppose the Soviet
system communist system we are all
people and we and and and the and he
ends with this we all inhabit the same
small planet we all breathe the same air
we all cherish our children's future and
we are all mortal the national security
elite just didn't know what to do with a
man like this they were concerned about
his private life they thought they were
snooping on his private life you know
one affair that I go into in particular
which unnerve them was his relationship
with a woman named Mary Mayer who had
the divorced wife of a former CIA
official named cord Meyer they had known
each other since they were in prep
school and they began a very I believe
serious relationship while Jack was in
the White House they Mary Meyer was a
pre hippie hippie a bohemian spirit a
woman who was determined to turn on the
Washington power structure using the
powers of LSD and her own I think charms
I think once the CIA found out about
this relationship which they did it was
just one more one more
you're cloud hanging over this
presidency I think what they thought of
Jack Kennedy essentially was this that
he was a morally compromised physically
debilitated and intellectually dangerous
president the the atmosphere the the
mutinous atmosphere in Washington became
so severe that at one point Kennedy who
frequently referred to the possibility
of his presidency ending violently
somehow in a coup or assassination and I
think he probably did this more than any
other president I can think of in
American history with the possible
exception of Abraham Lincoln but at one
point he goes to friends in Hollywood
and employs them to make a film version
of the book seven days in May which was
the bestseller by Fletcher Noble about a
political about a military coup that
comes close to Tom
a presidency Nebel had been inspired to
write this after interviewing curtis
lemay and hearing the kind of talk about
JFK that he was prone prone to the
pressures on Kerry were constant to go
to war in Berlin and Laos and Vietnam
but above all in Cuba Cuba could very
could very well have become the Iraq of
its day in fact there's a fascinating
National Intelligence Estimate produced
by CIA analysts about such a scenario
that was produced in 1962 that I came
across and it eerily reads just like
Iraq today what it says is if the United
States was to invade not like the Bay of
Pigs but an all-out military invasion we
would quickly sweep aside Castro's
forces and march on to avanná
triumphantly but we soon become bogged
down and lengthy occupation of the
island there would be terrorist attacks
on our troops our troops would respond
over respond civilians would be killed
the civilian population would turn
against us we become increasingly
isolated within the world because of our
unilateral military action
it sounds very familiar well I think
John Kennedy was no george w bush he
realized that was a possibility distinct
possibility he realized what the stakes
were he was determined not to get bogged
down militarily like that in Cuba and he
was determined to prevent the nuclear
holocaust which was a distinct
possibility throughout his
administration the Kennedys were
constantly trying to stay on top of this
world the showery world the CIA's secret
war on Castro and it was this particular
world that Bobby Kennedy cast his
suspicions immediately on the afternoon
of November 22nd he knew that the CIA in
the Mafia this kind of Frankenstein
monster had already come together in a
dark alliance to kill Castro he thought
he had stopped that but that alliance
had continued and we know from his
conversations that day exactly where he
was looking he was looking at the CIA
the Mafia and the Cuban exile community
it was a very dramatic moment in
American history at one point aids come
to him that afternoon say he has to
surround his house in Virginia with
security with federal marshals because
they don't trust the FBI or the Secret
Service at that point because they think
whoever's killed President Kennedy is
coming for Bobby Kennedy next despite
the dangers that always existed for
Bobby Kennedy from that moment on until
his own death in 1968 he was determined
from that moment on to find out who the
killers of his brother were and to
reopen the case he struggled with great
grief and depression the sense of guilt
that he should have prevented the
assassination of his brother
but after initial burst of energy and
sinking into a deep depression he
struggles out of this and he comes back
to political life because he knows the
only way that he can find justice for
his brother is to reclaim the White
House that the candidates have lost he
runs for Senate from New York in 1964
and then for the president see in 1968
an enormous act of courage not only is
he challenging a sitting president over
a war that was started or at least
escalated under his brother but he does
that he's taking his life in his hands
he knows that whoever has killed his
brother those forces are still very much
alert and threatened by Bobby's campaign
but he's deeply moved by the the wounds
that the country is suffering civil
rights the Vietnam War this endless war
like we have today the country had
turned against the war the public but
the government seemed determined to plod
on I came across this amazing speech
that Bobby gave in Sacramento a shopping
mall where he's surrounded as usual by
these clutching swarms of people it was
more a religious experience than a
political experience his campaign he'd
be clawed out he'd be bleeding and
scratched at the end of it
but I I when I hear these words I think
of our country today and and and and the
people who are dying and suffering in
Iraq what Bobby said that day in
Sacramento was whit was this which of
these brave young men dying in the rice
paddies of Vietnam might have written
the symphony which of them might have
cured cancer or played in the World
Series which of them might have built a
bridge or taught a small child to read
it's ours our responsibility to let
these men live that's the kind of I
think message that American leaders need
to deliver today and just as boldly as
Bobby did after Bobby was killed the
band of brothers as he called them the
men who had served the Kennedy brothers
so loyally and a number of whom he had
called on to help him investigate
secretly his brothers murder began to
drift away their heart was cut from them
at this point they weren't able to
pursue take up Bobby's mission and
pursue the case either his own
assassination or JFK's and if I could
I'd like to read you a fairly brief
section from the book about one of these
men particularly poignant story Kenny
O'Donnell who some of you know that name
who was a candy loyalist from the early
days in Boston and then became chief of
staff in the Kennedy White House so if
you'll just bear with me I'll read that
passage with my glasses
enjoy the view here for a minute
so this takes place after the deaths of
both Kennedys well begins before the
death of Bobby and you'll see where it
goes from there Kenny O'Donnell and his
fellow Irish mafia war horse Dave powers
were eyewitnesses to history on November
22nd 1963 riding immediately behind the
president's limousine in the Secret
Service backup car the two men saw it
all that day before the motorcade began
JFK attentive as always to political
details had asked them to take seats in
the follow-up car so they could closely
observe the reactions to him and Jackie
from the crowds the two men could never
forget what they saw that afternoon as
the shots rang out Powers blurred Kenny
I think the president's been shot Oh
Donald quickly made a sign of the Cross
as both men stared intently at the man
they had loved and served ever since he
was a scrawny young congressional
candidate a final shot quote took the
side of his head off Oh Donald would
later recall we saw pieces of bone and
brain tissue and bits of his reddish
hair flying through the air the impact
lifted him and shook him limply as if he
was a rag doll and then he dropped out
of our sight sprawled across the back
seat of the car I said to Dave he's dead
O'Donnell on powers both World War two
veterans distinctly heard at least two
shots come from the grassy knoll area in
front of the motorcade but when they
later told us to the FBI they were
informed that they must be wrong if they
did if they did not change their story
it was impressed on the man it could be
very damaging to the country so
O'Donnell did alter his account to fit
the official version testifying before
the Warren Commission that the shots had
come from the right rear the direction
of the School Book Depository powers
however could not be fully shaken from
his story even though one of the Warren
Commission employees who took a
statement kept interrupting him Powers
insisted that he had the impression that
the noise appeared to come from the
front as well as from behind which is
probably why Dave Powers was never
invited to testify before the Warren
Commission as the more amenable
O'Donnell was five years after the
assassination O'Donnell confess
to his friend Boston congressman and
future Speaker of the House Tip O'Neill
what he had dutifully hidden from the
public he had heard two shots from the
fence on the grassy knoll O'Neil who was
dining with O'Donnell and a few other
people Jimmy's Harborside restaurant and
in Boston was stunned that's not what
you told the Warren Commission he said
you're right replied O'Donnell I told
the FBI what I had heard but they said
it couldn't have happened that way and
that I must have been imagining things
so I testified the way they wanted me to
I just went didn't want to stir up any
more pain and trouble for the family I
can't believe that said O'Neill I
wouldn't have done that in a million
years I would have told the truth tip
you have to understand said O'Donnell
the family everybody wanted this thing
behind them it's clear from O'Neill's
account and one given by Dave powers who
suggested that Hoover himself pressured
or dialed to change his account that the
FBI played a key role in this fateful
decision and this fateful distortion of
the record but it's equally obvious that
O'Donnell was also responding to signals
from the Kennedy family and that could
only mean his close friend Bobby the man
whom his life and career had completely
been completely intertwined with ever
since they were Harvard roommates the
intensely loyal O'Donnell who was as
close as a brother to Bobby would never
have changed his story without first
checking with Kennedy and Bobby had made
it clear that he was not ready to
publicly question the official story
about the assassination whatever his
reasons for hiding the truth about
Dallas
O'Donnell's decision weighed heavily on
him the Kennedys had been his life tough
taciturn utterly dedicated he had put in
slavish hours at the White House but he
laughed at the notion was a sacrifice
tough job my ass it was the best job I
ever had he would say but now the man he
had served was gone he wished the
bullets that hit him instead he told his
wife and instead of helping bring the
president's killers to justice he was
misleading the country the assassination
was the end of his life his son Kenny
jr. told me he never was the same again
none of the men around Kennedy were but
especially him
O'Donnell confided what he really
witnessed in Dealey Plaza to his son as
well he said there was fire from two
different directions recalled the
younger
and his father would bitterly complain
about his experience with the Warren
Commission I'll tell you this right now
he told him they didn't want to know Oh
Donald called the inquiry inquiry the
most pointless investigation I've ever
seen pulling out the records of his
testimony to show Kenny jr. he would
point to a passage with disgust and say
look this is ridiculous
they weren't even looking for an answer
to this O'Donnell might also have been
disgusted with his own performance
before the Commission in the months
after Dallas O'Donnell would devote
himself to helping Jackie the two had
clung to each other like old soldiers
ever since the assassination as they
flew back to Washington that day both
were stained with Jack's blood Kenny and
Bobby found solace by gathering friends
at Jackie's Georgetown house and
entertaining her with old stories about
Jack
but O'Donnell could not put Dallas
behind him but he and Dave powers
witnessed that day continued to work
inside them O'Donnell experienced
wrenching bouts of nausea for six months
after Dallas Powers began suffering
violent headaches the pain was focused
in the same part of his skull where he
had seen the bullet blow off the top of
his friend's head he couldn't get the
quote sickening sound out of his own
head like a grapefruit splattering
against the side of a wall O'Donnell
began drinking heavily when friends
warned him to go easy on the stuff the
man nicknamed the Cobra would fix them
with a cold glare and tell them go to
hell in mind your own business but he
listened when Jackie and Bobby sat him
down and talked to him
it worked observed his daughter Helen he
seemed to step forward into human
company again but Kenny O'Donnell never
fully recovered he just lived the rest
of his life with a heavy heart set of
son he ran twice for the Democratic
nomination for governor in Massachusetts
but his political talent was as a
behind-the-scenes man not as a
campaigner and he lost both times
Bobby's assassination was the final blow
Kenny Jr was with his father the night
he heard his father had just spoken to
RFK on the phone about the California
primary results it's over his father
told him after hearing the history had
repeated itself that's all he said we
called Kenny jr. that was the absolute
end
when O'Donnell died in a Boston hospital
in September 1977 at age 53 his family
requested that the cause of death be
withheld but the Press reported he had
succumbed to a liver ailment there was
no more Bobby to tell him to put down
the bottle his memorial service was held
at st. Matthew's Cathedral where he had
a sport at Jack's casket 14 years before
walking slowly up Connecticut Avenue
from the White House at the Irish wake
held afterwards at the Mayflower Hotel a
Boston politician feminist about his
fallen friend without the Kennedy he
said O'Donnell was the music without the
heart Thanks I just want to leave you
with this because again this is the part
of the book that I'm being challenged by
some historians about but I feel you
know very deeply about it and there was
a moment when I was interviewing Ted
Sorensen the eloquent speech writer who
who really lifted I think the rhetoric
and and the the vision of the Kennedy
presidency so high and Sorensen still
living and still deeply pain to talk
about those days with intrusive
journalists like myself but at one point
he's wrestling with this idea he said I
know that Jack Kennedy's dead live for a
purpose I just can't believe he died for
a purpose he said it would give me great
consolation if I knew this dear friend
of 11 years this man I served so closely
had gone to Dallas knowing what the
stakes were knowing that he was
confronting these dark forces and that
they killed him for what he believed in
what he was trying to do with the nation
the truth is I think Ted and his heart
does know that's the case because after
Bobby died he delivered a beautiful
eulogy for Bobby Kennedy at the law firm
where he works still to this day in New
York and he was he was challenging this
idea that it was already taking hold in
the media that the Kennedys were cursed
he said there is no curse upon the
kennedys they have met their share of
ill fate because they had more than
their share of courage and the
conviction required to try and tempt
fate
they died heroic deaths because they
lived heroic lives and if there's one
thing I would like my book to accomplish
its its conveying that sense of the
Kennedy presidency thank you very much
[Applause]
yes I mean what I really wanted to do
was create an emotional narrative around
the Kennedys story you know it's
particularly the assassination is such a
dark labyrinth and so many researchers
have gotten lost it's a rabbit hole one
friend of mine who actually has written
about it Anthony summers warned me
before I did this book but I I think by
following Bobby Kennedy's light into
this dark tunnel its enormous Lee
revealing because he was the Attorney
General of the United States he did know
more about the dark forces in American
politics and I think any public figure
of his day and of course because of his
love for his brother he was utterly
committed to getting at the truth the
truth is I think Bobby was on the right
path and when he was the phone calls he
made that day basically I think now a
consensus has developed around those
suspicions among the most intelligent
assassination researchers including by
the way the Church Committee in the
1970s which people forget and the House
Select Committee on assassinations both
of those committees and the best
investigators for those committees were
looking at the same area they thought
something very dark had happened within
the CIA a secret war on Castro and those
guns had been turned against Kennedy
instead so yes I do hope the book
creates you know you're not supposed to
say Oliver Stone because
he's been so pilloried and you know
stigmatized but at least that film
created enormous public uproar and
forced the government to release
thousands of documents the law was
passed in 1992 called the JFK records
collection Act
many of the documents that I used as a
researcher were as a result of that but
the CIA continues to sit on thousands of
documents that are very relevant and a
good friend of mine Jeff Morley again is
going to court this summer to try to
compel the CIA to release these
documents he's a reporter with the
Washington Post and I think is the
really the reigning expert on this yes
is there anything other than what you
wrote in your book about her because I
find that so intriguing you know that
whole situation and how she suddenly
died an overdose of a drug that hadn't
been prescribed on her that's right well
yes it's one of the one more bizarre
footnote in the whole Kennedy's story
Dorothy Kilgallen for those of you too
young to remember I remember on What's
My Line but she was a gossip columnist
who work for the Hearst Newspapers and
she at one point scored really the you
know the scoop of her career which was
an exclusive interview with Jack Ruby a
jailhouse interview and she was a very
good crime reporter actually she had a
background of that sort of tabloid you
know you know crime reporter and she
came back telling friends that she was
going to break the Kennedy case based on
this interview with Ruby you know Bobby
Kennedy thought Ruby was also a very a
key to understanding the crime because
within 24 hours of Jack Ruby who was a
nightclub operator in Dallas shooting
you know Oswald on national television
and stunning the country including
myself as a kid and my brother I think
all of us were watching I thought was a
crime movie within 24 hours of that
Bobby Kennedy has learned about Jack
Ruby's connections to the mob I have
memos that actually Justice Department
memos showing that bobby was on it
immediately and Bobby later tells his
press secretary Frank mankiewicz when I
looked at the phone calls ruby was
making before Dallas it looked
my witness list for the rackets
committee the Senate rackets committee
where Bobby was chief counsel in the 50s
so I think Dorothy Kilgallen was onto
something then the question of course is
why did she die suddenly and strangely
that night there's many many deaths like
this in the Kennedys story
III mentioned two or three of them
because I think they're particularly
interesting I don't know for certain
what happened to her that night she was
a drinker she was known to take pills
but there were a number of anomalies as
you know about the crime scene that
night and they certainly raise questions
the night of her interview with jack
ruby or no it was sometime later she was
working on a story that she was actually
going to include in the book and one of
the other strange things about is the
manuscript that she was working on was
never found
salon has it though and it's about it's
going to publish it I heard any other
questions I think I've answered
everything huh no good question
well I've been asked that question every
place I've gone on this book tour I
think the heart of the Kennedy family at
least when it came to investigating
these crimes really died with Bobby
Bobby was the last kennedy who had the
investigative zeal the fire in the belly
to get to the bottom of this crime Teddy
I interviewed Ted before the book they
made it very plain to me his press
people that he wouldn't talk about the
assassination the interview would be
over if I brought it up they said that
you know often of course family
tragedies the the pain eases over time
but they told me with Teddy it's
actually more painful today in some ways
his memories of his two brothers so I I
didn't talk to him about it I know the
kids Bobby's kids who I interviewed with
his grown children Bobby jr. and Joe
Kennedy Kathleen I interviewed them
about it and they all said Kathleen was
very eloquent about she's
you have to understand how we were
raised we were raised to look forward
not backward and somehow we would I
think emotionally collapse if you were
to look backward well that kind of I can
understand that as a survival mechanism
but it carries its own emotional baggage
I the truth is I don't think it is up to
the Kennedy family to get to the bottom
of this it was a crime against American
democracy I think these assassinations
it's up to the judicial system the
political system and the media all of
which have failed miserably to shed much
light on this the Kennedys
you know I think have gone through
enough well exactly and he knew that he
knew that people would suspect him
immediately because it happened in Texas
and he he everyone knew how ambitious
ruthlessly ambitious he was I don't
believe that Johnson had prior knowledge
or was involved in the conspiracy and in
fact he himself was stunned I think and
terrified that afternoon I tell the
story of how they were before Air Force
one took off from Love Field in Dallas
they were looking for the new president
and Godfrey McHugh who is the Air Force
attache in the White House was you know
looking all over and they finally opened
a bathroom door and he was crouched in
the bathroom muttering conspiracy
conspiracy they're gonna kill us all
later Bill Moyers who was his young aide
he came up to him while the the plane
was flying back to Washington and LBJ is
looking pensively out of the window and
he says mr. president what are you
thinking about he goes I'm wondering
when the missiles are going to start to
fly and Jamie Galbraith who's I think a
very astute political historian the son
of John Kenneth Galbraith and he happens
to be a professor in Texas he told me
his interpretation of that was that he
thought the tensions that everyone knew
were boiling within the Kennedy
administration had exploded and Johnson
thought the military taken over and they
were about to launch a nuclear war a
preemptive strike on the Soviet Union so
I think Johnson was genuinely terrified
I could go on but I mean one great
tragedy about this of course is that
Bobby and he Bo
suspected a conspiracy but because of
their mutual poisonous hatred for one
another they weren't able to put that
aside and I think work together to solve
the crime died of a galloping cancer
yeah
whilst trying to talk or trying to still
talk to Governor Warren who refused to
meet with him that's right he wanted to
be taken out of the Dallas jail because
he knew what happened I think in Dallas
jails taken back to Washington so he
could testify openly about what he
thought had happened and they refused to
do that I know there's speculation about
whether the cancer was induced or that
sort of thing I just don't know enough
to comment on that back here
one point was made I don't remember if
it's in The Times or an article with you
but someone's I think Society the Saints
speech you cited that was very
aggressive and forward but then said but
then a week later he delivered a hawkish
speech and it was a refutation responses
no my remarks today and those reviews I
think simplified the portrait I tried to
give of the Kennedy presidency because
yes JFK was very much a man of his times
he did not want to be Adlai Stevenson or
John Kerry or any of the Democrats who
get rolled in presidential races by
hawkish Republicans and he actually
outfoxed Nixon in the 1960 election by
running as more of a hawk the famous
missile gap and and and he you know he
said he vowed to liberate Cuba during
that presidential campaign so he's very
much a man of his times you know in his
inaugural speech you see again both of
these themes he says you know only if we
have enough arms will we be powerful
enough not to use them and of course he
did set off a major escalation in the
defense budget and the building of a
enormous nuclear arsenal so Jack Kennedy
is a complex guy and he's fascinating to
me because what he's doing I think on
the one hand is through this use of
hawkish rhetoric and through some of his
policies keeping his political opponents
at bay they're never able to do what
they you know did to Clinton and say
Dukakis and and in every Democratic
leader virtually you can think of
because he did come off as muscular on
foreign policy and so on he'd been a
world war two hero and that was very
important to him to have that posture
but the proof is in the pudding I think
when you look at what Kennedy did again
and again when the chips were down when
they're trying to get him to go to war
in Vietnam to escalate there seriously
or Cuba or nuclear war
Berlin I mean that's what he was being
pushed to do Jack Kennedy slipped the
knots of war he was a very artful dancer
and that's his great beauty I think and
I think that provoked enormous rage on
the part of these hardliners within the
national security establishment because
they weren't able to best him he bested
them again and again so it's a complex
story and I think those reviewers didn't
capture that that sense of him to get
this opened up again can you envision a
person or a process that would be strong
enough or influential enough to get
behind this as opposed to you know
journalism and books and well here's the
only like that here's the thing the one
thing that makes me hopeful about the
times we're now the last time the system
cracked open where we really did have a
lot of new information not just about
the assassinations but about other you
know abuse is on the part of the CIA and
the FBI was of course in the 1970s after
the Vietnam War and after Watergate and
I think those crises created such
pressure and and and cracks in the
system that the system itself was forced
in some way to investigate itself you
also had a democratic presidency with
Carter in power coming in saying that he
wanted to open you know the doors to the
secrets and so on and you had to I think
very aggressive committees looking into
this I see some parallels today we have
this war in Iraq that's terribly
unpopular war that really has produced I
think great kind of chaos within the
political system in a way because the
you know the Bush presidency is so
isolated in its it's reckless pursuit of
this war I think against the rest of the
political establishments will at this
point and so if you now on top of that
get a democratic presidency particularly
progressive one maybe someone like
Barack Obama
or even a Hillary Clinton although you
know Democrats sometimes they're loath
to open those doors to they have to have
a lot of pressure on them to do it at
the same time so that's the third
element of this there has to be I think
something of a catalyst here and it has
to come from the American people and I'm
not sure what that will be you know
Oliver Stone stillness I said earlier is
one of them but books don't seem to have
the same impact as movies I'm sorry
Becky this is sort of a post Kennedy
question but I'm wondering if you what
your thoughts are on why subsequent
Democrats have been unable to replicate
that outfoxing of the Hawks well it's a
good question I mean I you know think
JFK was extraordinary leader and so far
we haven't been blessed with that the
same kind of combination I think you
know sort of a poetic vision yeah you
know connected to sort of a hard a hard
and tough in Boston Paul you know and
raised by a father I think in the ways
of power very shrewdly you know whatever
you think of Joe Kennedy an old corrupt
you know patriarch he you know schooled
his boys well in the way it's a power
and you know Clinton was a shrewd
politician but I don't see the same
ability that that JFK had to stand up to
the hardliners the way that Kennedy did
again you know my concern with a Hillary
or Barack is will they have the same
kind of backbone because you know it
seems like Hillary at this point is so
concerned with establishing her bona
fides when it comes to you know her
military expertise and so forth you know
Jack Kennedy after the Bay of Pigs was
willing to say screw you to these guys
you know Schlesinger Arthur Schlessinger
told me he had complete contempt for the
his own Joint Chiefs of Staff he thought
that they were empty suits and I just
don't see that same kind of willpower
yet among the Democratic field today
yes that's a big question and I think I
got criticized for that too and one of
those reviews
well Howard Hahn of course was a
legendary CIA guy part of the secret war
in Castro very ardent anti-communist
another Kennedy hater hung out with a
number of these people who were later
associated yeah you know to doubt with
Dallas and hunt and then of course
becomes famous for his role as the head
of the Watergate burglary team well
hunt didn't talk you know didn't talk
didn't talk people wanted him to talk
about what he knew in his retirement
he's a cagey guy a disinformation
specialist a novelist a fabulous you
know so you know you you have to take
things he says with a grain of salt of
course but interestingly what he does at
the end of his life under and with under
the encouragement or prodding of his
oldest son st. John Hunt is to begin to
sort of unravel some of these secrets
and I think his book is here American
spy he does it partly there but that
process was aborted when his second wife
Laura hunt freaked out because she
thought he was telling too much and his
lawyer and they stepped in at that point
and so what his book does is something
very odd it does it Oh J what it does is
sort of says if the CIA was involved in
the assassination the president this is
how they might have done it and he
stopped short of going all the way but
what he did with his son with notes that
I've seen handwritten notes and an
audiotape and a videotape is to go
further and what he says there is really
mind blowing because what he says is
1963 I was invited to a meeting at a CIA
safe house in Miami where the plot to
kill the president was discussed and I
was asked to join the plot I declined
because one of the other CIA officials I
didn't trust he was an alcoholic which
he was named William Harvey and so I
played a side lines role I was a
benchwarmer
well that's remarkable too and you know
Rolling Stone was the only publication
really to jump on that and give it the
kind of I think attention to deserved I
know 60 minutes was looking into it
well now people are just dismissing the
messenger saying you can't trust hunt
you know he made things up but the fact
is he didn't make stuff up about the
assassination well he did what he said
was all along the Soviet Union or Castro
was behind it
so why at the end of his life would he
suddenly incriminates agency and himself
it's curious I mean I I don't know
entirely what to make of it but I think
it deserves more attention than it's
gotten from the media yes would you
point to as the best piece of evidence
that Oswald was not alone shooter was
not what the lone shooter where to begin
well I mean just to name a recent one
there's a new study of the bullet
fragments from the crime scene Dealey
Plaza FBI metallurgist who said that
based on his study of those fragments
they must have come from two different
guns but I mean you know for me I'm not
a forensic expert in what happened in
Dealey Plaza I didn't want to go Dan
that was a rabbit hole I didn't want to
go down for me what was convincing to me
I just have to say was talking to people
who had been there or who talked to
people you know like Kenny O'Donnell's
son who said this is what my dad told me
it was the eyewitness testimony people
who were in the motorcade that day and
in my chapter on Dallas I try to create
a sense of what it felt like to be in
those cars because they felt like hunted
animals and they felt like the gunfire
was coming from multiple directions and
they were caught in a crossfire that's
what it felt like and they weren't just
hysterical people who had no sense of
guns or what they sounded like these
were World War two veterans and so to me
it's hearing from these people exactly
what it felt like or reading their
testimony Abraham Zapruder this
wonderful man this Russian immigrant
this dress manufacturer who very
patriotic guy standing there with his
you know home movie camera taking his
pictures and capturing these horrible
moments and then later screaming they've
killed him they killed him they ship
they shot him down like a dog Jackie
Kennedy's saying they killed him I'm not
taking
my Gor drenched Chanel suit off her
famous pink suit because I want them to
see what they have done to my husband
that was what they felt like that's what
you know you could say well it in the
you know the the trauma of a crime
many people say different things but
there was just so much evidence like
this eyewitness testimony you can see
pictures today people pointing up at the
grassy knoll the motorcycle cops running
up the hill
I think clearly someone was firing from
the Book Depository
but clearly fire was coming from some
other place as well and are you open
with a comment on the forgotten author's
name but the 16 hundred page book which
yes supposedly goes to everything
have you just curious if you read that
book and what is your thoughts on all
the points he makes and all the details
that he goes through to refute that
right no it was a joke because I haven't
had the time to read yet but I have read
the introduction I've read the parts
that relate to my book about Bobby
Kennedy and those parts don't inspire
confidence because what bully OSI does
is something very superficial he accepts
what Bobby Kennedy was saying in public
and this is an interesting story and
this is a big part of my book because
what Bobby Kennedy decided to do was to
accept the Warren Report publicly
because I think he felt if he were to
reject the Warren Report publicly all
hell would break loose in the media
there'd be a firestorm and he wasn't
prepared to publicly open this case or
because he knew he didn't have the power
the very day that he learns his brothers
killed his power begins to evaporate as
Attorney General I begin the book with
the kind of chilly phone calls he gets
from jag or Hoover his arch nemesis the
head of the FBI who tells him with
almost a sense of pleasure Bobby says
that his brother has been killed he
knows that the FBI is not going to
follow his directions after that and
they're in charge of the investigation
LBJ again the new president hates
Bobby's guts and vice versa so his
powers fleeting and in true Kennedy
fashion what he's doing is going
underground and doing it himself and
going to trusted aides you know he
slipped back into the Justice Department
after he was in the Senate to look
secretly at files with Walt Sheridan
this former FBI man who was a
right hand investigator he tracked leads
to Mexico City in New Orleans when
garrison was reopening the case he was
doing this very privately but anybody
who knows anything about Bobby in fact
it's in the two standard biographies by
Arthur Schlessinger and Evan Thomas of
Robert Kennedy that Bobby Kennedy
privately dismissed the Warren Report as
nothing more than a PR exercise may
aimed at lulling the American people to
sleep well
boolie OC certainly has read those books
and so for him to just blindly accept
what Bobbi was saying strategically in
public as the truth about what Bobby
Kennedy really thought happened in
Dallas is ridiculous
so that doesn't inspire confidence and
how the bullets hit him and the problem
they had about I'm sorry
what about Conley yes well Conley also
thought that there was shots from his
second gun he thought he was hit by not
by the Saint the magic bullet and so
that was his feeling too he tried to
blur it later and say you know that
Oswald was the lone gunman but there was
a different bullet which is inconsistent
of course so but yes he also and he and
his wife Nellie had the you know their
testimony went against the official
story
Bobby the shrapnel to be examining his
body right right what what role would
Nixon have played he have any idea he
was in Dallas that day yes and again
there's a lot of rumors about Nixon was
he in on it somehow I don't think so but
Nixon thought there was a conspiracy
there's a fascinating passage in Bob
Haldeman memoir in which when Nixon's
you know in trouble
Watergate has started to you know creep
closer to the White House in desperation
he tries to get the CIA to get him out
of this fix he's in and Richard Helms as
head of the CIA at the time a very
serpentine character as you'll see in my
book and he sends Bob Haldeman with this
mysterious message to Helms he brings
Helms into his office Haldeman says you
know the president says if you you know
this Watergate thing gets out of hand
that the whole Bay of Pigs thing could
be blown the whole Bay of Pigs thing
could be exposed and of course the Bay
of Pigs this is like you know ten years
before and you know Helms who's normally
very composed and crafty character jumps
up and says you know we had nothing to
do with the Bay of Pigs well of course
the CIA had everything to do with the
Bay of Pigs and that's a historical fact
and he wasn't denying that
and so Haldeman is puzzled about this
and he later talks to Ehrlichman his
sidekick and they figure out that Bay of
Pigs is Nixon's code for the JFK
assassination for Dallas and so
basically what Nixon is doing is trying
to blackmail the CIA and says I know I
know about you and Cuba that whole
operation and how it backfired against
Kennedy and got him killed and I'm gonna
you know threatened to expose you unless
you help bail me out here so I think
that was very interesting
revealing incident yes over here
think are the more intelligent
assassination investigators that you
mentioned earlier yeah sure I'm they're
acknowledged in my book because a number
of them were very helpful and generous
and they it didn't have to be because
you know sometimes people are more
proprietary about these things but
Anthony summers someone I mentioned
earlier I thought Tony summers who's of
Irish journalist you know did I think
one of the best early books on this it
was called conspiracy and then the title
was later changed to not in not in your
lifetime or our lifetime and again Jeff
Morley who's just completed a book it
will be coming out next year this
Washington Post reporter I mentioned
Peter Dale Scott who's a great scholar
over in Berkeley who's been at this for
years his book deep politics was very I
think interesting there was a book on
this appreader film by a Wisconsin
historian named David Rhone that's also
very good that came out two or three
years ago we can talk more about that
your interest in having a bibliography
I'd be happy to to help you out with
that but but there are a number of them
they're quite good yeah for those old
enough to remember when it comes to this
issue of was Kennedy a Cold War
a liberal how did he stand people forget
how conservative and how right-wing so
much of the country was in the 60s and
going back to our school I remember when
Kennedy was killed there were and there
was a school where a lot of the power
will be from California came Reagan's
kitchen cabinet Nixon's advisers and so
forth we're thrilled that Kennedy had
been killer Cheers I remember in my
classroom that was announced that he was
killed
ya know exactly in Southern California
was a bastion of John Birch or you know
activity in fact Kennedy twice in his
life decided to go into the heart sort
of the the belly of the beast and and
confront that sentiment the sentiment
that said any negotiation is treason
which is what they felt and one occasion
was in Los Angeles where he delivered a
famous address at the Hollywood
Palladium and there were thousands of
demonstrators out in front right wing
demonstrators calling him a traitor and
the second time of course was Dallas and
you know another amazing speech to read
besides this famous peace speech which I
quoted from earlier American University
was the speech the candy would have
delivered at the Dallas Trade Mart if he
had lived and what he essentially says
is you know we we must get over this
sense as a country that negotiation that
peace is weakness and and again just a
very radical notion at that time it is
today every camp every you know you look
at the Republicans that are all trying
to out do each other when it comes to
rattling sabers and their debates and
the Democrats you know to some extent
are too I mean even Barack Obama saying
you know Ron won't be off the table and
all of that
well that's rhetoric you know that maybe
they have to use in a campaign as I said
JFK did it earlier but the question is
will we get some kind of visionary
leadership at some point if a Democrat
has elected someone who's willing to say
you know let's rethink America's role in
the world do we have to be it does
America have to rule through
intimidation
you know again again Kennedy would say
things like we are just one country in
this world in another beautiful speech
he made that I quote in my book were
just one country we have to learn to
live in a multipolar world where we
don't dominate everything and I mean you
know his rhetoric is just so what's the
word is so relevant for for today's
world and again I hope that is conveyed
in the book but yes I mean he was up
against enormous ly reactionary forces I
don't think he would have necessarily
had an easy time defeating Goldwater in
64 that's another reason he had to go to
Texas he knew he had lost the whole
south when I read these books they drive
me crazy there's a book by British
historian saying that Kennedys were you
know remiss on civil rights and they
didn't care about sell vegetables yes
they were slow on civil rights that's
clear they were very afraid of splitting
the Democratic Party of losing the
Democratic South and they did they did
finally do the right thing and that's
what happened they split the Democratic
Party something we still see today that
started with Jack Kennedy because he
finally stood up and he did the right
thing on civil rights and so he had to
go to Texas because that was along with
Florida probably the only states in the
deep south he could have won so the
country you know we all think of him as
this charming charismatic prince who
would have had an easy time being
reelected in 64 but the truth is he he
probably would have had a tough tough
campaign
and the fact that spas Reagan met Oswald
when he came back from the Soviet Union
and helped Oswald get back to Texas and
spas Reagan was a Nazi collaborator from
the Ukraine originally and why he would
help Oswald get back to Dallas is is a
mystery to me and it's also mr. me why
the CIA hired Reinhard Galen who was
Hitler's top Intel official on his
Eastern Front in the Soviet Union
right now you're down a tunnel that I I
wasn't able to go down but yeah I mean
the major point you're making is very
interesting one which is you know Oswald
defected to the Soviet Union and then
came back with with surprising ease
Senator Richard Schweiker from
Pennsylvania who on the church committee
looked into the Kennedy assassination
said it made a very famous statement the
time saying the fingerprints of
intelligence are all over Lee Harvey
Oswald and I believe that's true maybe
one more and then we'll call it a day
and evening any others well thank you
very much for your patience David
Talbots new book brothers the hidden
history of the Kennedy years the author
is founder and former editor-in-chief of
the online magazine salon David Talbott
was recently interviewed by Terry Gross
on fresh air to hear it
visit npr.org and search his name